let's take you across the Downing Street
this is what the first conservative
cabinet for 18 years looks like David
Cameron denying the cameras in to see
his new appointment that was put in
place we've seen a lot of familiar faces
there you can see their defense
secretary of course Allen Foreign
Secretary Philip Hammond there are also
a lot of new faces in the Canada's
making within the education secretary
it's a deal of new appointments in the
last couple of days John Whittingdale
given a Sajid Javid sole job as culture
secretary also new faces Greg Clark
takes over from Eric Pickles there's
three civilians Norman and secretary
she's retained her job another new face
amber Rudd Hastings & rye MP she's got
me rollin from the cabinet into energy
and climate change Jeremy Hunt has
retained his job in health of course
you
according and welcome everyone before we
start I want everyone around this table
to be absolutely clear what we are here
to do and who we are here to do it for I
think it is absolutely vital that in
every decision that we take every policy
we pursue every program we start it is
about giving everyone in our country the
best chance of living a fulfilling and
good life and making the most of their
talents that's what this government is
going to be about and some pundits might
call it blue-collar
conservatism or being on the side of
hard-working taxpayers I would call it
being the real party of working people
the dignity of work the dignity of
having a paycheck being able to keep
more of their own money to spend as they
choose a home of their own the peace of
mind and security that comes from being
able to raise a family and have a decent
and secure retirement those are the
down-to-earth bread-and-butter issues
that we were elected to deliver on and
that is what we're going to do in this
part of course you must also support
those who can't work as I said on the
steps of Downing Street five years ago
those who can should those who can't we
always help that is the principle we
should always pursue I want our reforms
in education and welfare to be about
true social justice and genuine
compassion helping people to get on and
make the most of their lives and
supporting those who can't and the
agenda of bringing our country together
whether that's making sure the economy
works for everybody and every part of
our country or the agenda of bringing
the United Kingdom together that is
going to be absolutely key to the
success of this government and also when
you remember what we were elected
this doctor right in here is the program
we have a mandate to liberal or this
will be a different government it's not
a coalition government so we have proper
accountability no trading away of things
that are in here
the ability to deliver this that is one
of the most important things we can do
to restore trust and faith in politics
when you vote for something you get it
and I think what we're going to do thank
you we can say goodbye to cameras